to Maxwell mcgaha there's a bunch of
bargains coming oh that just right I am
maximum mcbarnett over this background I
always forget because when I'm getting
ready it's just a green screen Jaime and
then it comes to life could you do me a
favor and step back one just one step
just step back what no that's at the end
you just want yours in do it all right
no oh no where are the bargains are they
up here are they back here is this good
not right here yeah too close too close
no I'm getting the thumbs up from the
producers that guy that they're better
leave it here that tatis about some
bargains this week max oh well you know
folks we've had a lot of fun on the
internet today we're with it being you
know the first of April and all but I
want you guys to know that the bargains
I've picked out this week are wait for
it no joke there was a great glasses pun
in there are you jumping the gun on me
here all right so let sunglasses we've
got hitman absolution it's free right
now on xbox games for gold it's got sexy
ladies on does oh come on also available
on games for gold for Xbox is a little
game called deadlight now this is coming
out later in the month hitman absolution
it's free right now for games from gold
deadlight comes out towards like I
believe it starts on the 16th up until
the end of the month because you know
having a game free for the entire month
isn't confusing at all that game is
pretty cool though and it doesn't take
that long to be so well there you go
those speaking against I don't take that
long to be look it's everybody's
favorite game dungeon siege 3 this is
part of the dungeon siege complete pack
which I found on steam that comes with
dungeon siege 1 and 2 as well as dungeon
siege 3 and some dungeon siege 3 DLC now
I picked out that one because dungeon
siege 3 has a special place in my heart
I played it cooperatively with a buddy
and I know everybody hated that game
because it wasn't like the old dungeon
siege games but I think you should
definitely give it a shot also these
were the sweet glasses no I was gonna do
the joke with and it was gonna be it was
gonna be a real good job and which of
those glasses cost oh well I got on a
sweet big bargain which means I found
them in the bottom of somebody else's
desk same but is that the same place you
found that ty know this well this came
from Mary kisses desk because Mary Kish
is the queen of fashion
and apparently the bottom of peers desk
is where you find the free sunglasses so
there you go that's the bargains for
this week folks thanks for tuning it
thank you very much max Okajima more
feed you step back into the into the
lower now I'm going to spare was very
dear bargain by taking me home bargains
/ well this is as far back as I can go